le prix des aliments a augmenté en
raison de la hausse des coûts des
fournisseurs et des producteurs
les grands patrons des grandes épiceries
du Canada sont venus dire hier au
parlementaire à Ottawa qu'il ne profite
pas de l'inflation pour gonfler leur
profits tout de même on peut se demander
s'il n'y a pas un manque de concurrence
dans le marché des épiceries avec nous
ce soir Louis et Bert qui est professeur
titulaire en stratégie des affaires à
HEC Montréal bonsoir louisbet est-ce
qu'ils ont raison monsieur Weston et
Monsieur la flèche qu'on vient de voir
de dire qu'il ne profite pas finalement
de l'inflation pour augmenter leur
profit qui ne sont pas responsables de
l'inflation alimentaire ils ne sont pas
responsables en effet pour l'ensemble de
l'inflation ils sont peut-être
responsables pour une partie de
l'infection mais il faut pas oublier que
les supermarchés c'est seulement le bout
de la chaîne alimentaire et si on veut
vraiment comprendre les sources de cette
inflation là mais il faut d'un côté
regarder le contexte macroéconomique où
il de l'inflation pas seulement dans
l'alimentaire mais dans tout plein
d'activités le pétrole
notamment une augmentation des coûts
augmentation de matières premières aussi
du coût des matières premières que ce
soit le bois les graines les différents
grains et donc il y a un contexte
macroéconomique mais du côté de
l'alimentaire il faut regarder à la fois
aussi les transformateurs parce que les
supermarchés ce sont essentiellement des
revendeurs de produits fabriqués par
quelqu'un d'autre alors si leur
fournisseur augmente leur prix
ça augmente les coûts des supermarchés
mais j'ai quand même des profits qui ont
augmenté de 3 milliards 600 millions
depuis 2020 j'ai un taux d'inflation des
aliments achetés à l'épicerie au mois de
janvier de
11,4%. c'est très c'est très très élevé
et c'est le reflet justement de bruit de
la rentabilité des supermarchés nos
supermarchés au Canada vous avez il y a
cinq chaînes qui représentent 80% du
marché il y a pas beaucoup de situations
dans le monde ou c'est aussi consolider
aussi concentré donc en effet il y a
peut-être des enjeux de concurrence mais
si on veut véritablement comprendre
l'inflation il faut aussi remonter toute
la chaîne de l'alimentaire et même
remonter au niveau du producteurs aussi
une augmentation au niveau du par
exemple du prix du beurre du lait ou des
produits laitiers mais il faut être
aller voir aussi qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé avec le prix avec le prix du lait
mais moi je reste au bout de ma chaîne
alimentaire comme vous dites oui ben au
bout de la chaîne alimentaire j'ai un ne
ligopole de cinq entreprises qui
dominent 80% du marché est-ce que pas un
problème là
on vient de vivre une situation vraiment
exceptionnelle ces dernières années il
faudrait voir si cette tendance de
profit hors de l'ordinaire
continue dans les prochaines années ça
faudra faudrait le voir ou s'il faut
regarder au niveau du du retour sur
capital investi peut-être que si on
regarde la marche sur vente ok donc le
profil qui dégage sur chaque dollars de
vente
oui ça avoir une augmentation il faut
regarder aussi du côté du capital
investi parce qu'ils investissent
beaucoup parce qu'on regarde bon ils
sont investis dans le commerce
électronique dans
d'autres domaines donc il faut regarder
l'ensemble de la rentabilité et pas
seulement la marge sur les ventes mais
être un supermarché au Canada et c'est
être dans une industrie qui est très
rentable métro d'ailleurs à des
investissements records en 2022 dans ses
activités à
bonifier ou en tout cas poursuivi son
programme de rachat d'actions a baisser
sa dette à augmenter son dividende par
action il y a du cash chez Métro là chez
Métro chez les autres chaînes aussi les
autres aussi je vous donne l'exemple de
métro là qu'on a regardé de près et on
présume pourquoi à la place de racheter
des actions pourquoi il diminue pas
leurs prix pourquoi parce que la logique
économique dans quel on vit réduire ses
prix c'est
enfants de se créer un obstacle à
l'augmentation de ces prix là lorsque
c'est nécessaire de le faire
il faut en avoir pendant combien de
temps ils vont être capable de maintenir
ce niveau de performance là mais comme
vous l'avez dit
ils ont fait des investissements majeurs
ce sont des entreprises à profit
capitalistes qui recherchent des profits
qu'ils ont des actions c'est pas un
service public c'est une autre est-ce
qu'il devrait excusez-moi est-ce qu'il
devrait puisque vous parlez de
l'ensemble de la chaîne est beaucoup
plus transparent sur la formation d'un
prix au détail oui mais en fait écoutez
ce sont des entreprises ce côté en
bourse
leurs résultats financier sont
disponibles sont publiques justement
donc il est très facile de faire une
analyse de leur rentabilité
là faut peut-être aller voir les bourses
leur demander c'est quoi leur règlement
mais on est dans un autre dans un autre
pote mais il y a des secteurs où on est
capable d'identifier assez bien les
coûts lorsqu'on sait que par exemple le
prix des matières premières et déterminé
par le marché que ça soit le les grains
ou quoi que ce soit le pétrole les
transports je parlais une grande
entreprise hier et qui me disait que
leur coût de leur conteneur a pas
augmenter de 10% de 15% de 20%, et
augmenter de
500%. alors là la question c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec des coûts
de transport comme ceux là ça s'est
rétabli cependant les problèmes des
chaînes d'approvisionnement sont pas mal
terminés
sont moins sont moins graves ils sont
moins aigus que l'été mais écoutez vous
regardez en Angleterre les semaines
dernière il y avait des tablettes vides
dans les supermarchés parce qu'il
manquait tout simplement de produits la
chaîne d'approvisionnement ne fonctionne
ce n'est pas donc oui on a une situation
particulière ici c'est pas unique à ici
on peut le voir dans d'autres pays
l'inflation d'ailleurs est peut-être
supérieure en Europe on regarde les
données et l'inflation au niveau de
l'alimentaire et souvent plus élevé
encore dans ces dans ces pays-là
Royaume-Uni même en France c'est encore
significatif donc on n'est pas seul dans
ce problème là merci merci d'avoir été
avec nous